centros estatuas las puertas del palacio
de daom son sólo algunas de las 26
piezas de artefactos saqueados en la
época colonial y que fueron devueltos
por el museo quai branly de francia en
noviembre de 2021 después de tres años
de negociaciones algo que el presidente
de benin patrick talón tomó como una
prioridad desde que asumió el poder en
2016 y lo necesita
no vamos a pedir que se devuelva todo
las obras beninesas deben estar en los
museos de todo el mundo para que el
mundo vea la grandeza de venir
eso sí
estas piezas tienen un significado muy
particular eran propiedad real y fueron
tomadas como botín de guerra durante el
saqueo francés al reino de daum en
1892 algunas fueron devueltas pero
muchas permanecen en francia en los
palacios de ahome de donde fueron
saqueadas los líderes esperan que sean
devueltos
estoy feliz pero aun quedan muchos
objetos por recuperar como los de las
mujeres amazonas que perdieron la vida
peleando contra los franceses lo que les
pertenecía a ellas se lo llevaron los
colonizadores me gustaría que nos
devolvieran todo eso también las
autoridades esperan que la devolución de
estos 26 artefactos sean solo el
comienzo de un largo proceso de
restitución francia inició el proceso de
restitución con estas 26 obras creemos
que esto es sólo el comienzo y estamos
seguros de que es un movimiento que no
se detendrá pronto
solución
capa de éxito de de benin el presidente
macrón se comprometió el miércoles a
continuar este proceso de restitución
mediante el establecimiento de un marco
legal que facilitaría la devolución de
las obras de arte robadas al continente
africano